- A businessman 20
years ago wasn't famous.
- [Interviewer] He wasn't famous, no.
The internet is grossly underestimated.
(light music)
Thank you, my friend, not too bad.
- [Interviewer] Wow, this
is the head office, right?
- This is the head office.
- Yeah?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
but you are entrepreneur.
- Yes.
- Investor.
- Author.
- Yes.
- Public speaker.
- Your own sneakers.
- That's the best of the whole bunch.
- [Interviewer] What's, what do you know?
- You know, I think this
is being an entrepreneur.
But yeah, man, if you told the 20, 42,
if you told a 24 year old version of me
that I would be getting
paid millions of dollars
to be the face of sneaker--
- A sneaker.
- I would've laughed you,
I would've laughed you
out of my liquor store.
- How it's possible?
- I think it's possible
because the internet
is unbelievably underestimated.
This is a very important point,
I do not believe that anybody,
including biggest advocates,
are actually giving the
respect to the fact that
the internet became real life,
and real life became secondary.
And that's like uncomfortable for some.
And what I mean by real life,
of course I don't mean it like that,
what I mean by that is attention.
Attention is the absolute
asset of the world.
- [Interviewer] What do you mean, exactly,
with attention?
- Well, why does FIFA make an
unbelievable amount of money
during the World Cup?
Because every four years the entire world
pays attention to something,
and if somebody's wearing
a sponsorship logo,
if there's commercials doing it,
if there's events in
eight towns in Russia,
there's money to be made.
Without that attention--
- [Interviewer] There would?
- If nobody was watching,
Cristiano Ronaldo would not make
100 million dollars a year, plus.
People used to watch airplane
pilots and astronauts,
and they made more money.
Now they don't, they make less.
Today we look at fame
in many different ways.
I am now pseudo-famous,
which makes me laugh saying it.
A businessman 20 years ago wasn't famous.
The internet is grossly underestimated.
- [Interviewer] How did it all start?
- Tell me.
- For me as a person?
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
just when it all began.
- How it started is how it is today,
from the lemonade stand to this
sneaker is it's very simple.
I've always been a
salesman and a businessman.
It's now called an entrepreneur.
I always sold stuff, lemonade,
raking leaves, shoveling snow.
- [Interviewer] All toward reason.
- I was in Edison, New Jersey.
I was born in Belarus,
in the former Soviet Union.
I immigrated to the US.
Lived in Queens, then in Jersey.
Very humbly, we grew up,
we didn't have any money and then we
became a middle class family,
upper middle class, but
my parents spent money
like we were still poor.
I was a real hustler even before that,
selling pencils and
lollipops and lemonade ,
and gambling and whatever
the fuck it took.
I was a hustler,
and I was an entrepreneur
and a business kid
when it wasn't, that wasn't cool.
It was bad.
Grab my report card, D Rock.
(Sighs) I know they have
grades in different ways
in Europe and the US, but in America,
A is good, F is bad.
And, sorry about that.
A-B-C-D-F, you can see
here I was a terrible,
(laughter)
terrible student.
But besides gratitude and guilt,
no question do I wanna
stick it in the mouth,
stick it right to the parents and teachers
who slept on me,
who didn't understand what I was about,
who talked shit,
who I now enjoy the feeling
of them looking and saying,
"Hmm, I was wrong."
Nah, it's not like I wanna
razz them or make them upset.
All I want them to say was,
"I was wrong."
Not I wanna hurt their
feelings or make fun of them,
I just want them to say,
"I was wrong, I didn't see what he had.
"He was right."
I was right where the world was going,
they were wrong.
- [Interviewer] And do
you feel it everyday?
That drive?
- Mm hmm.
When you get shit on,
from five to 15,
and when you don't have a lot of stuff,
and when the world's
telling you you're losing,
and when your parents do a good job,
and don't hand you everything,
you fuckin' never lose that hunger.
I'm hungrier right this second
than I've ever been in my fuckin' life.
And I have a lot more than I've ever had.
- [Interviewer] Your parents also have
the entrepreneur mindset?
- 100%, my dad was an entrepreneur,
100%.
We came to America,
came to America, he worked
for his great uncle's liquor store,
eventually he bought it.
He was entrepreneur through and through.
100%, my dad is an entrepreneur.
I can never see my dad
working for somebody.
He'd be fired multiple times,
but so would I for different reasons.
Yes, that is in our DNA.
- What I'm looking for and what's,
you talk about the road to success.
- Okay.
- I'm very curious--
- Adversity.
- Yeah, how it's--
- Adversity's the road to success.
- [Interviewer] What do you mean?
Explain to the people to the
people that are watching.
- When you're hungry, you
have to hunt for food.
Let me give you one of
your not adversities.
You.
I don't know you, I've
known you for four minutes.
I could tell you right
now one of the things that
is not an adversity for you.
- [Interviewer] Tell them.
- You're a good lookin' dude.
You're good looking.
So, that wasn't one of the
things that drives you.
That came natural to you.
For a lot of boys, like getting girls,
because they're not pretty
was a big driver.
But other things could
be adversity for you.
That's, I'm fascinated by that.
Right?
Being a short male, adversity.
Not being good looking, adversity.
Being a bad student, adversity.
Not having money, adversity.
Like not making your,
Michael Jordan, who I hate, hate--
- [Interviewer] Why?
- 'Cause I'm a Knicks fan.
That's why Madison Square
Garden's right there.
Michael Jordan got cut from
his sophomore basketball
team and went on to become
one of the great basketball
players of all time.
Tom Brady, who I hate.
Hate.
Like hate, why?
'Cause I'm a huge Jets fan.
Tom Brady went on to become
one of the best quarterbacks
of all time,
and he was the backup
quarterback in college.
He went in the sixth round.
People don't get it, adversity.
Messi, let's use a little football.
Know short Messi is supposed to be?
He's short now, you know how
short he was supposed to be
before they started
injecting him with hormones?
That's adversity.
- You must feel it.
- 100,000%.
- But that's one thing.
- It's the thing.
- It is the thing.
- If you wanna talk about success,
success is predicated
on effort and ambition.
Where does that come from?
It comes from adversity.
Let me give you a weird adversity.
Your mom and dad were super successful,
and everybody was looking at you.
You're growing up and
you're growing up rich,
and everybody's shitting on you
because they're saying
no matter what you do,
your mommy and daddy gave it to you.
That fuckin' is fire for people.
Some people run away,
other people run into it.
What got them huge to prove to their dad
that they could be bigger than them?
I have two children.
One of them might run away, one might say,
"Fuck, that's a big mountain, fuck you."
- [Alexa] I'm not sure.
- Alexa, stop.
They're gonna say,
"Fuck you, Gary, Dad.
"I'm gonna climb your
mountain even bigger than you.
"Impact more people than you,
make more money than you."
It's adversity.
Adversity, look there's a lot of things,
but let me tell you one thing
that I think we will all agree on.
You have to be great at your craft, right?
To be successful, you have to be good.
Well, why are you putting
in all those hours?
You're either putting it in
because you love it, passion,
or adversity.
It's Star Wars.
Good and bad.
- What are the five top
rules for you from success?
If you had said--
- Self-awareness.
Number one, if you don't know who you are,
you're finished.
I could wish to be somebody--
- That's a difficult thing for a lot.
(Gary scoffs)
But how can they help it if they--
- I talk about it.
I just helped.
You just asked me, what
are my top five things
for success.
My first answer was self-awareness.
I think I'm helping, I think my answers,
and my nuance in the marketplace right now
is predicated on, I'm talking
about different things
than the entrepreneurs
that made it before me.
Yes, they talk about hard work.
Yes, I talk about
discipline and other things,
but I talk a lot more about this.
- [Interviewer] And what
is, what do you mean?
- Mindset.
- [Interviewer] Mindset, yeah.
- It matters, this is
the operating system.
People spend more time
updating their phones
than updating their minds.
This is it.
Is your perspective right?
Are you happy?
Are you putting yourself
in a position to succeed?
There's only one way
you can be a workaholic,
you love it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah for sure.
How many hours do you work in a day?
- 15?
- 15.
- [Interviewer] But how do
you keep the right focus then,
if you work 15 hours a day?
- 'Cause I, 'cause I love
it, 'cause I'm in my...
I don't know music well, but
like the crescendo moment,
ding, like that bing.
I don't know what I'm
doing right now, (laughter)
but like,
is that called a crescendo?
What is a crescendo?
None the less,
you know the, a perfect pitch.
Perfect pitch, right?
Ting.
I feel like I'm living my
life with a perfect pitch.
Like I'm doing exactly
what I should be doing.
- And when do you know this?
When you have,
a lot of people are searching
to do what they love, or--
- Here's what I could say.
I don't know if you know you've hit it,
or how do you know when you found it,
but I think you know
when you don't have it.
Right?
I think if you ask somebody
are you in a perfect spot
right now, a lot of
people could answer no.
You know and,
(stammers)
look I'll tell you something else.
I keep things unbelievably basic.
To me, happiness is about
doing what you wanna be doing.
Too many people focus on the money,
the things that come along with it.
I think you have to focus on the process.
You have to, you have to
focus on do you like it?
Nine, from 7:00 a.m. to 11:00 p.m.,
do ya love it?
- You have to do also different things.
I have two children.
- Me too.
- A wife, how do you keep
the balance also in life?
(clicks tongue)
- Communication.
- Communicate.
- 'Cause things change.
Things change.
And things change.
My son is now more into
sports in the last year,
I want to spend more time with him.
- [Interviewer] But you
also work 15 hours a day.
- Yes, but I play through extremism.
What's working for me
now is on the weekends,
I'm all out with the
family and I'm taken--
- [Interviewer] So that's for sure.
- For sure, for sure.
- The weekend is family.
- And that's already 100 days a year.
That's already a third of my time.
- [Interviewer] And in the
evening, when they go to bed?
- No.
Not me.
- Not you.
I understand why people should, could,
like to, not me.
Monday through Thursday.
See ya.
- It's Gary time.
- And that's real Gary time.
Mid-day Friday, night, Friday day night,
it really, Friday night and
the weekend, it's them time.
And then seven weeks--
- [Interviewer] But they have to on--
- Seven weeks,
besides the weekends,
vacation, two in December, two in August.
- [Interviewer] That's
also for sure, that's.
- For sure.
So now all of the sudden,
you're taking 35 days,
you're taking 100 days,
I'm taking 130, I'm
taking a third of my time,
minimally, with the family.
Now by the way,
some people wanna spend 80%
of time with the family.
Mazel Tov.
You do you.
- [Interviewer] But then
(laughs) you can't be successful.
- You can if you're--
- [Interviewer] Okay
this, what is it to this?
- Correct.
For me, I want to see this through.
What does that mean?
We all know a lot about ourselves
that we never say out loud.
Every one of us in here, I'm
looking at all of us right now.
Forget about everybody behind the camera.
There are three, four things
we know about ourselves
that we have never said to anybody.
Only to ourselves in
our own mind about us.
- You can now say it.
- You want an exclusive?
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
- You know, I think,
I'll give you an example.
I think I'm unbelievably selfless.
The reason people like
me is I do so much good,
but it's because I'm selfish.
And nobody wants to say they're selfish.
Like, but I am because I can't function
if I'm not happy.
How can I do anything good
for my family or my community
unless I'm happy?
You know why I'm bringing so much value?
'Cause I'm happier than most people.
You know why?
'Cause I don't give a fuck
what people think about me.
- [Interviewer] But that's
also a question for me.
How do you that?
I think a lot of people--
- I think I didn't do anything.
I think my parents and
my circumstance did that.
It's why I also don't have a,
I have an ego, but an ego for my parents
and for America.
When I think about I'm cool,
I think it means the internet,
America and my parents
won.
I'm the product.
I think a lot of people say to me,
when they get to know me, they're like,
"You're humble, you're
not a dick actually.
"I like you, you're nice.
"Whoa, you're humble"
'Cause I have a lot of energy.
I don't think anybody watchin'
right now for the first time
thinks I'm humble.
It takes a little while,
but there's only one reason I'm humble.
I don't wanna be humble.
I'm only humble 'cause it's the truth.
I'm succeeding, a lot more to do
with America,
the internet and my parents,
than I am with like oh I did this.
I'm the produt.
VaynerMedia,
that's me.
My kids, that will be
me and my wife, right?
That's, I'm the operator.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm very proud about VayberMedia.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
How many employees at the moment?
- 800 plus, London, New York,
LA, Chattanooga, Tennessee,
soon to be Singapore.
I'm proud of that, but me,
having 3.5 million followers on Instagram,
people saying I walk on
water and I'm thins guy,
da-da-da-da,
that's Sasha and Tamara Vaynerchuck.
That's being an immigrant form
the Soviet Union to America.
That's America having a system
where an immigrant can do that.
That's the internet coming
along at the right time.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's reason.
- !00,000%.
So I'm grateful.
I'm driven by gratitude.
I understand my perspective.
- [Interviewer] VaynerMedia,
800 employees at the moment.
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- [Interviewer] When did
it all start, Vayner?
- Vayner started in 2009, May of 2009.
It really started in September, 2011,
'cause the first two
years I was still wine,
I was writing Crush It,
I didn't wanna do client
services. (laughs)
But then I went all in in 2011,
in September.
And it's been an
amazingly fun seven years.
- [Interviewer] But I think you started
a couple years ago,
but now 800 employees, that grows.
Can you describe it--
- Yeah, we went from 40 to
800 people in seven years,
six and a half years.
Listen, I'm an operator.
I was 31 years old before I
started my first wine video.
I was 35 years old
before I made one piece
of business content ever.
So I was a businessman
before I was a personality,
and I think a lot of people
who watch forget that.
They see Gary Vee--
- [Interviewer] Vee as
the internet person.
- That's right, I'm Gary Vaynerchuch,
who's the producer and
strategist behind Gary Vee.
- [Interviewer] But you do
so much on the internet,
so I can understand
people see you as that.
- Oh, I always don't mind if
people are confused by me.
If they're confused by it being Gary Vee,
if they're confused that
I'm a motivational speaker,
my parents handed it to me.
They don't know the details
'cause they're busy,
and they shouldn't read
the story, they don't,
they hear my story I
built my dad's business
from three to $60 million,
and they hear it as my
dad gave me $3 million.
Not only is it not the case,
it was a $3 million business
doing $300,000 in profit,
but I built it for him.
I left my business at 34 years
old, when we started this,
that I built, to a huge company,
with no equity.
My dad owns Wine Library.
- [Interviewer] How do you do that?
Of course, I read something, ecommerce--
- Ecommerce, email,
being a salesman on the floor,
building an organization,
building a great pallette.
I was right about Australian, Spanish,
and New Zealand wines.
Being a practitioner.
- [Interviewer] What is the biggest thing,
the big thing what you
learned in all the years now,
with all the experience you have?
- That patience and self-awareness.
- [Interviewer] Patience?
- And self-awareness.
- [Interviewer] What do
you mean, can you explain?
- By being patient, not
wanting it now, now.
The biggest, the single biggest reason
most of the entrepreneurs
of this generation will fail--
- [Interviewer] 'Cause they want it too--
- Fast.
That's it.
- [Interviewer] They want to go to fast.
- That's right.
If you're, if you're a football,
proper football entrepreneur,
and you want it too fast,
let me tell you what you do.
You DM 433,
and you spam it.
- [Interviewer] Just. (snaps)
- Right, hey 433, post my video.
Hey, I'm selling this soccer
ball, football ball, excuse me,
please put it up.
Hey 433, I wanna do an event with,
you spam.
When you're patient,
you DM 433 and you say,
hey 433, I love your content.
I'm in the football space too.
I'd like to do something great for you.
When you're patient, you give.
When you're impatient you try to take.
And that is the fundamental breaking point
of today's environment.
- For you--
- You know why?
Because we live in a world
now that everybody looks
at their Instagram feed.
- [Interviewer] Just checking
what all the people are--
- It's all phomo.
It's all, they see their friends in Ibiza,
with champagne and pretty girls,
and they're like,
"Shit, if I can make some
more money real fast,
"I can go to Ibiza next year,
"and I can be with that
champagne and pretty girl."
Stupid.
That's the word, I don't like,
I don't like using stupid.
It's stupid.
It's doing many things wrong.
Number one, you're letting
somebody else dictate you.
You're worried about your friend Charles.
The fuck does your friend
Charles have to do with you?
Got it?
- Take it.
- It's all about impatience.
So patience is an
incredibly important pillar.
- [Interviewer] Work very
hard, each every day.
- Work very hard, each
and every day a lot,
if you want very big things.
- But how do you make the right choices,
each and every day?
- You don't know.
- [Interviewer] But how do you did it?
- In hindsight, because I
have empathy for people,
and I was good in understanding
what people were gonna do.
I understand that people value time.
So when I see a new technology
that will save them time.
Hey, Alexa, when does England
play in the world cup?
- [Alexa] England will play
later today at 2:00 p.m.
in Moscow against Croatia.
(laughter)
- Thanks Alexa.
That was faster for me to figure
out what time England plays
than looking at the phone, right?
If I, right?
First of all, it already
took me, where is my,
see oh perfect.
Actually where is my phone?
So already.
- [Man] Might be charging over here.
- It's charging, oh
actually I put it here.
Already, think about how much,
this actually really happened.
It took me longer to find
my phone before I went to--
- [Interviewer] How long?
Got it?
So why am I betting on voice?
- I needed some audio.
- Why am I betting on voice?
I'm betting on voice because it's faster.
Hey Alexa, what team did
Cristiano Ronaldo sign with?
- [Alexa] Cristiano
Ronaldo is joining Juventus
after the Italian club
agreed to a $123 million
transcript via Real Madrid.
The Portuguese forward
leaves Madrid with 451 goals
in 438 games.
- Alexa, stop.
That's faster.
- She did very good.
- That's faster than
me going to the phone.
So why am I now investing
in being the best at that?
Because I know in 2026, right?
In eight years when all of you realize
how much better that is than this.
It's going to matter.
That's why I made the right choices,
because I only care about one thing, one.
One thing.
The end customer, not me.
I care about my customer more
than I care about myself.
- [Interviewer] A lot of people,
a lot of business owners
and entrepreneurs tell me
they care about end consumer. (claps)
- They tell you.
- They tell you,
but they don't do it.
- They don't act it.
The fuck am I doing this interview for?
- Yeah, you do a lot of this.
- Because I bring value, I know
it's gonna bring you value,
yes I'll get some awareness
for my sneaker, cool.
But guess what, not a
good use of my 30 minutes.
I know that I'm gonna change
one kid's mind in this video,
for sure, maybe six.
I know that you're gonna
take this interview,
and leverage it to get other people.
- For sure.
- As guests.
So now I'm bringing value.
I know, I know, I know, I know.
- [Interviewer] That's how it works.
- So I don't care what people say.
I tell my audience all the time,
don't listen to what I'm saying.
Watch what I'm doing.
- And do it.
That is the best way to
get value out of Gary Vee,
is to watch what he's
doing, not what he's saying.
- But what is the most that you love to do
with doing this and inspiration?
Or the entrepreneurial time?
- Oh entrepreneurials, I hate
that people think I'm a
motivational or inspirational
figure.
Let me rephrase, that's not fair.
It's very nice, but it's like a bi-product
of being a good person
and a good entrepreneur.
And I think because I'm so successful
at producing content for
the internet right now,
and because I'm genuinely positive
and excited and motivated,
that it, some people
have me in that bucket.
And because Instagram, right now,
is the place where attention is,
and because of the limited
nature of the one minute video
and a picture, I'm
definitely more motivational
on that platform than I am on my podcast,
on my LinkedIn, on my, and
definitely in my real life
as an operating CEO.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
It's a part of my personality.
- [Interviewer] But it's
definitely not a lot--
- You know what, it's the mashed potatoes.
It is absolutely not the
steak or the lobster.
You know?
It's not the green beans,
it's the mashed potatoes.
I understand that.
But the motivational me
is the mashed potatoes.
The entrepreneurial operating executive
is the steak and the lobster.
- [Interviewer] And for the future,
what are your plans?
- I wanna be the single
most admired entrepreneur
of this generation.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's--
- Now, in a world
of incredible founders
like Bezos or Zuckerberg.
I don't think I'll achieve the most money,
but I think I will impact emotionally
the most entrepreneurs
and I have a funny feeling
that will get me more people to my funeral
than Mark or Jeff will get.
- Yeah?
- Or Elan.
I really believe that.
- [Interviewer] I understand they want
more, very much more busy with the people.
- I'm in the trenches.
Because that's where I come from.
I come from the dirt.
Even though I'm striving for the clouds,
- [Interviewer] For
me, just to understand,
just a recap for the road to success.
- Yes.
Self-awareness,
empathy.
You have to have empathy for your people.
You have to, I mean,
you know how much I love
D Rock, who films me?
That's the first time I've
ever seen him drop his camera,
and it dropped on your guy.
You know how, (stammers)
you didn't get to see the angle.
I was watching him while we've
been doing this interview.
He was upset for five
minutes, he's still upset.
- I am upset.
- You have to have empathy.
Do you care about other people?
I think that's how you
become consumer centric.
I care more about my customer than myself.
I care about my employees,
I care about my employees first,
my customers second,
and me third.
And honestly, actually it's not even true.
Employees, customers,
the company, VaynerMedia.
Right, Wine Library.
Do you know how many
times I've paid people
a severance from my
bank account personally?
Not from the company's?
Because I thought that I
was doing the wrong thing
by the company and I
wanted to do something
for my former employee?
It came out of my pocket.
Most people are the reverse of me.
They want all the money.
The only reason they
have employees or company
is for their personal money.
I'm not.
So I think empathy,
self-awareness, empathy,
work ethic.
I hate that so many people
in the liberal world,
and I'm very socially liberal,
but my socially liberal
friends take it too far.
Work matters.
There's nobody who's
gonna beat me in Europe
who works 25 hours a week.
Fuck you, not shot.
You can't beat me if I work
one day more than you work
in a week.
- [Interviewer] For sure.
- Now, you may say
you're beating me in life
'cause you're happy, cool.
That's fine.
That's a different conversation.
But you're not gonna build
a bigger fucking business
than me.
And so I think work ethic matters.
- [Interviewer] And for you, happiness?
- Happiness is, this is what
happiness is based around.
- Just--
- Happiness is everything.
It's bigger than the road of success.
Happiness is the fucking
North Star of life.
You know, for me, when you're self-aware,
you're already happy.
Because if you really know you're,
the biggest reason people
are upset, my friend,
and don't win is they don't
wanna face who they are,
they wanna make pretend
they're something else.
It's why entrepreneurship's so scary.
Being a footballer,
the field tells you in black and white
that you're not good enough.
Right?
You know why entrepreneurship's scary?
'Cause you just say you're
an entrepreneur and you are.
And we're accepting that right now.
For now.
But if I said I'm a singer, you would say,
"Yeah, but are you, are
you gonna win Grammys?"
If I said to you I'm a basketball player,
you would say,
"That's nice, but do you play in the NBA?"
But when people say
they're an entrepreneur,
we don't say yet,
"But yeah, do you have
a successful business?
Or do you say entrepreneur
on your Instagram,
and you sell four t-shirts a year on it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, must
be a good entrepreneur,
if you have to describe it, when are--
- I think a good entrepreneur can't breath
not being an entrepreneur.
And I think 99% of the
people right now that say
they're entrepreneurs
are in it for the money.
- [Interviewer] I wanna
thank you for this time.
- I appreciate it.
- You're a great legend, man.
- Thank you, brother.
Thanks for having--
- It's nice to be here.
- Thanks for having me.
(R&B music)